my friends grace mercy and peace from
God our Creator and from Jesus Christ
our Lord amen earlier this weekend Jeff
and I had a celebratory dinner to mark
the fact that he has put up with me for
six years of marriage we went to our
favorite Italian restaurant although
there were several empty tables in the
restaurant the hostess seated us at a
small table right next to a family who
was already enjoying their dinner and I
was pondering the menu and I could hear
them talking and soon realized that the
young women at the table was definitely
a Yale student and I tried hard not to
go into work mode so I zeroed in to the
menu again but nonetheless we were so
physically close to them I was
uncomfortable but at least the table on
the other side just 12 inches from my
right elbow was empty for a few minutes
then a father and daughter were seated
there and I could smell his Cologne and
I could hear her grumbling about school
and I heard the father say your mother
and inferred that the girl's parents
were divorced honestly I wasn't
eavesdropping we were just that close
together I love small quaint restaurants
with a few tables the food is usually
amazing and I realize it is my own
discomfort with eating so close to
complete strangers that is the problem
here and I realize this is a pretty
ridiculous thing how privileged I am to
be in a restaurant to have an
anniversary to celebrate and the fact
that I thought of wanting more space in
this context is just wrong but Ian just
assured us of our complete forgiveness
in Jesus Christ so I will let that go
and we'll just use this as a sermon
illustration you get my point though we
don't eat with strangers if you eat most
of your meals in a dining hall chances
are you'd rather sit by yourself or
certainly find a friend to sit with
rather than look out for that person who
is sitting alone and might seem a little
awkward
to go join for conversation it's fair
actually because it can be fairly
awkward to just walk up and sort of
barge in on someone who might be wanting
some quiet time but it still makes us
uncomfortable to think about it even
eating together with people we do know
family members or friends is on in a
decline mealtimes are more likely to
involve cars or iPhones or TVs then they
are conversation with other people
instead we check in with our loved ones
in little spurts little emails brief
skype conversations little facebook
messages but much less often over meals
than in past generations eating together
is a lost treasure and I use that
language that we here in 2nd Timothy
guard the good treasure and I think
about what we have lost we are losing a
lot when we don't sit with strangers to
share common food and drink if eating
together is in fact a lost art why do we
bother with world communion sunday is
this something that the church is
hanging on too much longer than the rest
of society just for the sake of
tradition well we have 10 kinds of
communion bread today just because it's
tasty no way we celebrate world
communion sunday here to remember why we
do communion at all because these are
the gifts of God and we are hungry world
communion sunday reminds us that we
share these gifts with others from all
around the world and we shared that
hunger for God as well globalization is
not news at Yale over two years ago Tony
Blair launched his faith in
globalization initiative we hear the
word globalization all over the place
here Yale is focused on being a leader
throughout the whole world students here
will have the chance to study abroad
look around we are an international
community even here today
a so I think we are already globally
minded this is not news but how often do
you actually think about Christian
communion with others around the world a
global day a globalization that started
long before we had a word for it as you
walk up the aisles to receive Communion
here do you ever think about a similar
meal happening in a church in Korea or
South Africa or Switzerland the way we
tend to come forward one by one open
hands here might give us the false
impression that it is just about an
individual and a tiny chunk of bread
dipped in wine when in reality it is
about God loving the whole world it is
about Christ's body made present to us
in bread and wine but also that Christ's
body includes people from all around the
world this is a meal in which we get to
eat with complete strangers we come
empty-handed to this meal because no
amount of money can buy these gifts even
if we have eaten breakfast we come to
this table with a spiritual hunger that
the grace of God only can satisfy and we
pray every week give us this day our
daily bread so the small amounts of
bread and wine we receive at communion
remind us that God does provide
sustenance enough for today yet
sometimes we doubt that it will be
enough that this little bit of bread
that these few drops of wine will
actually sustain us in Luke's Gospel the
disciples cry out to Jesus increase our
faith they had just heard a stern
warning from Jesus about the punishment
of those who stumble they had just heard
from Jesus a command to be on guard
always ready and the disciples respond
please increase our faith otherwise we
will not be able to do this
so how does Jesus reply
if you had faith the size of a mustard
seed the smallest speck you could say to
this mulberry tree be uprooted and be
planted in the sea and it would obey you
if it's not easy to tell if Jesus words
are meant to challenge or comfort the
disciples we don't exactly know the
inflection he was using was he scolding
if only you had faith the size of a
mustard seed you could actually move
this tree if only or was he comforting
them calm down a little bit dear
disciples you don't need to have faith
the size of an apple or watermelon or
Texas you need to have faith the size of
a mustard seed that's all do you know
how small mustard seeds are in the palm
of my hand I probably have 100 of them
they are tiny if you look at your
bulletin and find the dot of an eye that
would be about the size of a mustard
seed yet they're pretty hard to hold on
to someone came up and bumped into me up
here they would go flying or if I get
really animated in a minute and start
throwing my arms around they are going
everywhere it seems like having just
this tiny speck of faith should be easy
but you and I know that life happens the
trouble bumps into us that distractions
overwhelm us so Jesus increase our faith
make it easier to hold on to the
disciples requests to Jesus is an
important reminder that faith is a gift
we cannot force it upon ourselves or
others it is gift it is a small mustard
seed in a hand and then a cry out to God
when we look down and realize our hands
are empty and then looking down again to
realize God has provided
bit of daily bread so I think Jesus was
trying to both challenge and comfort his
disciples then and now on the one hand I
think Jesus does supply us with mustard
seed doses of faith and some days these
are easier to hold on to than others but
i think it is God who is in the business
of uprooting trees and moving mountains
we need to stay in the realm of metaphor
here because if you think about trees
crashing on the roofs of homes or
mountains crumbling in an earthquake we
label these acts of God yet it's pretty
dangerous theology to say that God was
punishing anyone who is damaged or died
in those calamities so we stay in the
realm of metaphor when we think about
moving mountains in the language of
Matthew or uprooting trees in the
language of Luke God is in the business
of large seemingly impossible
transformations on this earth and maybe
we have a small small hand in that if we
have had some chance to make some
difference in the world some positive
change in the world may be working
toward the cure of a disease may be
working for policy change that will look
out for our brothers and sisters in need
if we have had the chance to do anything
good it is by the grace of God it is God
working through us that lets these
things happen take a moment to think
about your earliest memory of Holy
Communion was it a ceremonial first
communion as a child did it happen later
in life what did you consume was it a
little dry wafer was it a hunk of bread
do you remember how the drink tasted or
were you watching from afar are these
memories that make you feel welcome and
included or maybe excluded what were
your earliest memories of communion
world communion sunday is where these
memories that have shaped us meet
today's reality of Christianity we bring
those familiar stories of home with us
and remember that other's homes look
very different we remember that the
church is growing fast in some places in
being persecuted in other places on
world communion sunday we remember that
on altar tables around the globe
Christians are using a common starch and
a festive drink whatever those elements
look like and those cultures to remember
that on the night in which he was
betrayed Jesus gathered for a meal with
his friends this is a meal in which we
sit very close to strangers an
invitation and a choice we make to eat a
meal that no amount of money can buy and
to hold in our hands symbols of God's
grace for the whole world thanks be to
God in every language in every way we
can possibly say it thanks be to God
amen